wie durft hier 1 rollenspel te doen op het podium
Bam eerste hand zie ik daar omhoog gaan
ik Wil even dat jullie dit moment onthouden
want jullie waren allemaal 1 beetje huiverig
om jullie hand omhoog
te steken Jesse
die onderneemt hier actie
en we hebben al gezien dat actie nemen
beloond dus Jesse
je krijgt 1 cadeautje van ons MacBook air
1 MacBook air
laat het duidelijk zijn
actie nemen wordt beroemd
overal in je fucking leven
als je zo hier op het stoeltje zit en denkt
oh leuk allemaal vandaag
je bent heel gemotiveerd
vanavond en morgen slaap je in 1 nachtje
en vervolgens
sta je op en GA je weer gewoon zelf
dezelfde manier verder als wat je altijd al deed
dan zul je ook altijd krijgen wat je altijd kreeg